الاشتباكات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع عمت شوارع الخرطوم
ومدن كثيره اخرى لكنها لم تختصر على الارض
فقط الصراع امتد ايضا الى الساحه الرقميه
ومنصات التواصل الاجتماعي بين حين واخر
ينشر الطرفان صورا ومقاطع مصوره لتاكيد او
نفي انباء سيطره احدهما على بعض القواعد
العسكريه او المرافق الحساسه مبنى
التلفزيون السوداني مثلا الدعم السريع
نشرت مقطعا للحظه سيطرتها عليه ليعود
الجيش وينشر بيانا معلنا استعادته وكذلك
الحال مع السيطره على القصر الجمهوري
فيديوهات ومنشورات رقميه تنفي او تؤكد
نشرها كلا الجانبين كل ذلك يدخل في اطار
الحرب النفسيه التي لا يقل تاثيرها ابدا
عن العمليات العسكريه على الارض والاعلام
ومواقع التواصل احدى ادواتها الرئيسيه
بهدف التاثير على اراء وعواطف الاطراف
المعارضه